اليوم اوود اشارككم رؤيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لمسار السلام في الشرق الاوسط
وبالاخص الصرع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني الذي
طال
امده للسنوات طويله شهدت هذه المنطقه طري
خ مؤق من التحديات
والصراعات وفي قلب هذه التحديات يبقع
الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني ان الولايات
المتحده تؤمن بان السبيل الوحيد لتحقق
السلام دائم وعدل يقن في حل الدولتين هل
يضمن الامن لاسرائيل ويحقق العداله
والكرامه للشعب الفلسطيني بوجود دوله
اسرائيليه ودوله فلسطينيه قابله لياه في
السنوات الاخيره شهدنا توترات متزايده في
جازا مثل التي نشهدها اليوم تؤكس امق
الازمه وحاجاتنا الماسه لحلول
جدريه لكن الصرع اوسع من جازا وحدها انه
يشمل معانه وتطلعات شعبين ويسعين للعيش
بالكرامه واللام
لهذا فان الولايات المتحده تدعم جهود
السلام التي تتضمن اداره فلسطينيه موحده
تكود كل من الدفه الغربيه وغاز وتؤ ازز
مسار التنميه والاستقرار
الحوار والتفاوض هما المفتاح لتجاوز
الخلافات وبنا مستقبل افضل لجميع ابناء
المنطقه الولايات المتحده تؤمن بان الحل
الدل والدائم للصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
يمكن تحقيقه فقط من خلال التفو على حل
الدولتين حيث يعيش الاسرائيليون
والفلسطينيون جانبا الى جانب بالسلام
وامان نحن ندعم محلا يحفز الامن لاسرائيل
ويوفر الكرامه والازهار للشعب الفلسطيني
في الدوله فلسطينيه قابله
للياء في هذا الاطار تعمل الولايات
المتحده على تشجيع جميع الاطراف على اتخاذ
خطوات بنا تؤز فرص تحقيق
السلام كما اننا نستمر بحث الطرفين على
الامتناع عن اي اعمال قد تؤدي الى تصعيد
التوترات او تقوي فرص السلام او اي اعمال
انفه احديه الجانب في الوقت ذاته نرا
اهميه تعزيز علاقه الدوله العربيه مع
اسرائيل الخطوات التي
اخذتها بعد الدوله العربيه نهو ادبيه مع
اسرائيل تساهم في توفير مناخ ايجابي
للسلام لكنها لا تغني عن ضروره التواصل
الى حل
دولتين نحن نشجع الجهود الراميه لتعزيز
التعاون والتفهم في المنطقه
وفي نفس الوقت نؤكد على ان اي تقدم في
العلاقات يجب ان يرافقه تقدم ملموس نهو
الصلام
الشامل ندرك ان طريق الصلام ليس سهلا
ولكنه ضروري وقد حان وقته والولايات
المتحده منتظمه بدورها كشريك وميسر لهذا
السلام وتعامل جهده لتقريب وجهه النظر
الحوار
البنا نحن نؤمن بان الشرق الاوسط يمكن ان
يكون منطقه تعيش وازدهار وان شعوبها تستحق
مستقبل يسوده السلام
والامن